when i was watching the new movie you
get in the ring with the ball and this
ball throws you like a [ __ ]
right you get it you get a concussion
you break your wrist you break your ribs
and you even say you lost uh cognitive
abilities for three months yeah i got a
brain hemorrhage from that so my
cognitive abilities were in steep
decline after that hit what does your
wife say to you does she say stop we
have enough money i almost lost you is
she freaked out by this or is she not
allowed to sort of make any sense of
this and has to keep that away from you
oh no uh no one in my family is
uh happy with the stunts
and this la the the bull hit was
the worst hit i've ever taken
from a bull or maybe
period uh
like i said my cognitive abilities
really declined i remember taking some
tests
the neurosurgeon said uh do you have
trouble paying attention
right now and i said yeah why he goes
because you scored a 17
on uh
uh
my attention
uh
that's out of a hundred does that scare
the [ __ ] out of it what is it about you
that that doesn't scare you laugh at
that and it's uh you know
i laugh now
right at the time i was like oh no
because
you know i had to go under all these
type of treatments this transcranial
magnetic stimulation
which
they buzz your head with these magnets
for about 30 minutes at a time for like
oh god i would say
10 to 12 treatments over a series of two
months and it's supposed to help with
the depression and you know help with my
cognitive skills
so
it was it was it was a tough one to come
back from i was trying to edit the movie
at the time but i couldn't sit still at
this point now now that you got the new
movie in the can would you now explore
with the therapist why you are so
attracted to danger yes i i can now go
into it with the therapist because
like after talking to the doctors and
and i knew going into this film that
after this i can't take
put myself on the line with stunts that
can forever
change my life
you know
so
and after the bull hit i'm like i think
i've done enough right i i don't have
anything to prove
uh and i still have con you know control
of all my faculties and uh
so i don't need to do large stunts
anymore uh
so i can talk to my therapist about that
now i'm sure it has something to do with
self-worth what do you think it is about
self-worth you know
this
this last concussion
did
you know i did slip into a little bit of
a depression uh with this last
concussion
uh which that hasn't happened before
right
so
i can't take any more hits to the head
the doctor's like you just can't take
any more hits to the head what kind of
depression do you go through like what
what do you mean what was the depression
my brain was just
playing tricks on me
right uh i got
really depressed and
um
focused on things
uh
no i didn't we didn't get there
but i i did have to start medication for
the first time in my life
and
yeah anti-depressant
yeah it completely turned me around that
and you know doing therapy and
yeah it was it was a it was a really
hard recovery from this last injury
but i'm great now like i feel like i'm
the best i've ever healthiest i've ever
been
you